[Applaudissements]
thiérache de l'udc je sais pas encore
mais certainement
je crois qu'on a on est en train de voir
en train de disséquer les images toutes
les images voilà de palma ma camille
combal vous restez avec tolstoï moment
est grave
le moment est grave jean-luc va désigner
celui qui va partir faire koh lanta je
vous le dis prochaine saison sera tout
pour on appellera la chaîne on la perd à
la production je connais assez bien
on l'appellera denis brogniart avec qui
j'ai quelques contacts denis on vous
retrouve bien sûr vendredi à 21h sur tf1
pour une nouvelle session de kolontar on
vous regardera bien sûr on aimerait se
rapproche de la réunification savent que
c'est exactement mon jean luc qui avez
vous choisi pour aller participer à koh
lanta
le prochain qui soit célébrités opa
célébrités 1 a donc on peut prendre
n'importe qui alors quelqu'un qui sait
très vite réjouit quand il a cru que
j'allais partir à koh lanta et qui me
fait de plus tout à fait donc pour
partir à koh lanta et je suis sûr qu'il
va être très très bien c'est un de ses
rêves
gilles verdez
gilles verdez on fera tout pour qu'ils
fassent koh lanta j'vous dis j'essaie de
pas dire si rim dix fois non mais tu
m'as réaffirmé donner coup j'ai eu de la
chance et je te promets que l'an passé
n'arrive et j'aime m'occuper de toi père
les inversions de zizou place j'ignorais
ce qui plaît vraiment logique
c'était mon rêve c'est les amérindiens
depuis 2001 non mais c'est vrai même
dans ces trucs et ce regard si la baisse
du titre clermont chéri
orapi soeur pour que tu peux pas avancer
[Applaudissements]